so getting into our final video on blue
Marvel we pick up now with the fallout
of anti man's attack on Adam Brashear
and counter subsequent desire to destroy
all life in the world
what Griffo does here is actually really
cool where the actions of Connor Sims
were largely depicted as being in the
realm of your average stand-in villain
with his motives touched on the final
issue provides some valuable insight
into his character what we're told is
that in his mind
Connor is not insane and instead is
doing what's best for Humanity in truth
this is almost indicative of the
argument of the Watchmen comics when
Ozymandias claimed that destroying the
major cities of the world would force
humanity to work together where sims
seeks the allied destruction of all
things the motives behind their actions
remain the same and that the actions of
humanity in years past whether it be the
Holocaust under Hitler were the ethnic
cleansings under Joseph Stalin humanity
has turned a blind eye to the suffering
of its own people and in turn
demonstrated that it doesn't have the
right to exist anymore
from here we switch to the Avengers
Tower with Reid stark Brashear Aries and
Carol Danvers as they watch the events
unfold within a section of this story
Grove out depicts a battle on two fronts
the first is with Connor Sims using its
power to spark atomic explosions in
major cities around the world but the
second is the end fighting within the
ranks of the Avengers what I mean here
is that star creed and Pam were under
the belief that brashears power could
have been enough to overcome Sims but
the conflict at the end of the last
issue proved that this was not the case
through some measure which can only be
assumed as a result of Sims bathing an
antimatter energy his power has greatly
increased to the point that sheer force
cannot bring him down now Gerber takes
this opportunity to demonstrate both the
intelligence of a shear but to also
focus on the matter at hand regarding
brashears belief that no one else
understands Sims the way that he does
the case that blue Marvel makes here is
that because the power of Sims and
himself are essentially the same atom
wants to sink his energy with Sims and
let out a massive amount of positive
energy if this hypothesis is correct the
chain reaction would cause the
antimatter energy of Sims to come into
contact with a positive matter energy
let off by Brashear what this means is
that because the power of an T man is
largely tied into antimatter energy it
would be like two trains colliding into
one another the result is that the
energy let off by Brashear would be
destroyed but so would an T man
however for Reid the potential explosion
of this magnitude could eradicate the
earth completely but because Bashir sees
this as a risk worth taking this puts
him in direct conflict with the Avengers
team and the Fantastic Four now if I
were to be honest here I would make the
case that at this moment this is less
about storytelling and more about giving
us a chance to see blue Marvel fight the
Avengers which isn't really something
out against the reason why is that from
the time his character first appeared
Bravo had basically provided us with the
belief that brashears power was
incredible and scale and so I had really
been looking forward to the idea of him
facing off against the Avengers and more
specifically this century now in terms
of the story from the point of Bashir
his argument isn't that the Avengers are
incapable his argument is that he is the
only person who truly is aware of what
anti man is capable of since he views
himself as the foremost authority on
antimatter energy on earth now something
I'd like you to notice here is that this
is a vast amount of arrogance on
Breshears part while he is extremely
intelligent I would make the argument
that his experience in dealing with
people has put him in a cynical mindset
regarding the rest of society in essence
he's walking a knife's edge and his view
of what it means to be a superhero seems
to be the only thing that separates him
from Simms in terms of their personal
goals this is compounded on by the fact
that when the Avengers arrive he simply
refuses to listen to their case by their
own charter the Avengers exist as the
mightiest superheroes on earth both in
terms of abilities and bravery and so
the very existence serves to safeguard
the planet the fact that Brashear
refuses to listen to their side of
things seems to indicate that for him
stopping Simms is more of an obsession
than carrying out the role of ensuring
the safety of the planets occupants now
something that I really enjoy during
Breshears fight with this century
following his defeat of the rest of the
team is that Gravano throws a century's
on experience into the fray what I mean
here is that when Robert Reynolds first
showed up in Marvel Comics he was quite
literally a man suffering from multiple
personality disorder where he only had
two aspects of himself and that he had
the good side of Reynolds and the evil
void his character had spent years
hiding from himself and even went as far
as to create a piece of machinery that
constantly wiped his existence from the
minds of the Earth's population when his
character was rolled over into the main
Marvel Universe during this story who is
the century under the New Avengers the
focal point of his character was his
attempt to effectively hide away from
the world
and blame everyone else for his
inability to control the void and so as
the to fight the true beliefs of Adam
Brashear finally make their way out what
Griffo tells us is that the excuses of
wanting to save the world or stabbing
sims are all just a mask and the true
motive is over sheer lie in the fact
that he resented being asked to step
down by President Kennedy
he also resented being told that he
couldn't be a superhero because of the
color of his skin
and he hated the fact that even after
acquiescing to the demands of the US
government he was still treated like a
criminal because of something that he
couldn't control now this is
stupendously important because what this
does is provide humanity to brashear
stepping away from this comic for second
and into the real world we've all
experienced instances where we were made
to walk away from the things that we
loved sometimes this was due to the
inevitability of growing up and other
times it was due to circumstances
outside of our control but the fact
remains and even if only in this moment
we can truly identify with bashir on a
personal level more so than we ever
could before and so as a battle rages on
between Reynolds and Brashear
Ruvo gives us the epitome of a strength
level when blue marble knocks the
century through the atmosphere and into
orbit with a single punch to put this
into perspective this would be like
Brashear attacking the Hulk in his
angriest form and sending it into space
with one hit what's also really cool is
that this moment does not go unnoticed
by the rest of the Avengers with Wonder
Man commenting that he's never seen
anything like this before
stark takes the opportunity to plead
with Brashear that even if he's right
there's no guarantee that his plan to
combat Conor would be successful without
destroying the planet while this moment
seems a little unnecessary and that the
situation is dire and the Avengers
should go for any chance that they have
to ensure the protection of the planet
and truth this choice right here in
terms of whether they ally themselves
with bashir or not is what makes the
Avengers heroes and that they're
unwilling to put the planet at risk on a
gamble furthermore with Robert Reynolds
returning from space and mustering up
all the power he has he's finally able
to subdue blue Marvel by hitting him
with every ounce of strength in his body
where Reynolds is successful and able to
knock Bashir out the fact remains that
while all of this has been happening
ante man has been getting stronger
wiping out major cities across the globe
and making his way to New York
from here we transition to the Baxter
building with Reid start Carol Danvers
Robert Reynolds she-hulk Aries and
Wonder Man assembly what we're told is
that because Connor Sims feeds off the
energy of antimatter while he's been on
this planet a portal has been slowly
opening and growing wider leading to the
antimatter universe as a result these
antimatter particles have been meeting
the positive matter particles in the
main Marvel Universe and if left
unchecked will lead to a chain reaction
of destruction
that will wipe out all things in
existence in addition to this because
Brashear refused to listen to the
Avengers
Susan storm had brought in the one
person whom Brashear would probably
listen to his wife however before
Candice can speak with Adam the city of
New York is met with the arrival of
Connor Sims bringing a series of
antimatter storms women the Fantastic
Four and the Avengers depart in order to
attempt to save the city and so during
this time the story shifts its focus to
Adam Brashear and Candice which provides
us with a moment of importance between
the two where Bashir initially tries to
leave the scene before Candice can talk
to him the reason for this is due to the
fact that he hasn't quite forgiven her
for the betrayal of learning that their
entire marriage was a lie
and so what grubo does is give us a kind
of reconciling of sorts between Brashear
and Candice what Candice says is that
after taking some time to think about
everything that's been happening the
Brashear isn't really mad at her as much
as he's mad at himself the reason why is
because when he moved away from being
the blue marvel at the request of the
president his logic was rooted more in
fear than anything else what I mean here
is that the world wasn't ready for an
african-american to have the power to
openly defy the government without fear
of recourse people would have lashed out
in anger at seeing things change and the
result would be that Brashear himself
would likely have chosen sides after
being caught up in it all where Bashir
recognized that he could have been an
inspiration to the world he instead
chose to hide from it now this is
actually a pretty big moment for
Brashear and the reason why is because
within the context of this story he's
openly admitting to his wife that his
decision to remain hidden from the world
despite his better judgment was a
reflection of cowardice not bravery
which is something superheroes should be
and so Candace's wages his concern and
reaffirming Brashear that the man that
she knows is not the man Brashear
believes himself to be while his one act
could be considered cowardly by some the
racism he endured in his life and the
method in which he chose to handle it by
largely
away demonstrated a kind of bravery
rarely seen by others and that most
would have fought at the first sign of
offense and so after reconciling
Brashear Parts Company with Candice in
an effort to assist the Avengers now
this is something I'd like you to keep
in the back of your head because Candice
will play a pivotal role in closing out
the lingering paw threads at the end of
this story but transitioning to the
Avengers and the Fantastic Four the
story comes to in a sort of blue Marvel
saves the day scenario what I mean here
is that regarding his past in the
previous actions of society blue Marvel
himself is largely at peace and that
he's completely ready to embrace all
facets of who he is regarding his powers
and intelligence with Janet Van Dyne and
Hank Pym doing what they can to rescue
the citizens of New York from the raging
battle between the Avengers and the
Fantastic Four against anti man blue
Marvel appears denouncing Connors claims
of ending all life for the benefit of
mankind using his vast strengths and the
opportunity granted by his sudden
appearance taking Connor by surprise
blue Marvel quite literally knocks him
through a building and out of the
conflict now this moment is again
particularly important in that blue
Marvel asks for the trust of the
Avengers but is also willing to trust
them in turn the reason why this is
significant is because again this
highlights a dramatic change in
brashears view of the world and himself
by extending a willingness to trust he's
acknowledging that the world has changed
and that he no longer views himself as
the grudging protector of humanity Bella
willing leader for society with this in
mind Tony Stark grants were sure the
opportunity to lead the offense against
anti man using his knowledge of
theoretical physics encounters ties to
the antimatter particles the intention
of blue Marvel is to create a cyclotron
now to provide a little explanation here
a cyclotron can best be compared to a
tornado on a subatomic scale the
intention of Rishi rizz to basically
create a whirlwind effect which will
scatter the already destabilized
molecules of Connor and then charge them
with positive energy at the right moment
in simple English blue Marvel is going
to have Carol Danvers fly around the top
of Connor as fast as she can and a
clockwise position have Iron Man fly
around the bottom of Connor as fast as
he can in a counterclockwise position
while both individuals blast him with
energy at the same time she hope will
hit Connor as hard as she can requiring
him to expend his energy to withstand
her attacks and as a final piece of the
puzzle
sentry and Bashir will attack Connor by
flying into orbit
and back down to earth as fast as
possible and so with all the pieces in
place and everyone doing their part
while Conner is distracted Brashear lets
off a massive amount of positive energy
under the hope of literally scattering
the molecules of anti man and completely
disintegrating him however despite his
best efforts the plan proves to be a
failure with an T man maintaining
himself due to his fast energies that he
possesses now in this portion of the
story right now the power of an t man
possesses an astronomical amount of
power and in truth he could probably
hold his own against Galactus and so the
battle isn't so much about physically
fighting anymore as it is about Brashear
using his knowledge of science to
outclassed Sims during the conflict
though
Candice comes to the side of Adam in an
effort to ensure his survival through
the battle as a result when blue Marvel
is attacked by an T man with a blast of
energy it's temporarily absorbed by Adam
but because it's too much for him to
handle the HS energy is expelled from
his body and torches Candice now the
death of Candice is an extremely
important part of this story in that
this is the final straw for Brashear for
his character Candice was the last link
tying him to his life before but despite
the problems that they faced he still
loved her however seeing his wife killed
as a result of the actions of Simms has
shown the nature of Connor into sharp
relief in the sense that Brashear now
recognizes that his former friend cannot
be reasoned with and that his insanity
now dominates the mind of an t man this
sentiment becomes evident when Adam
begins attacking an T man with every
ounce of energy that he has during this
time he tells Connor that he tried to
reason with him to help him see that the
world was changing and people were
better than they used to be and worth
saving but because Connor refused to see
reason and only intended to satisfy his
drive to end all life based on a wrongly
held belief the only option left to
Bashir was to kill him and so flying
into the depths of space
Brashear completely cuts loose for the
first time in the story by expelling all
of his energy due to not having to worry
about saving the planet we're losing all
of his power at one time the plan to
kill Connor comes to fruition when his
atoms are dispersed across the cosmos
and he simply ceases to be now picking
up one week later the events of the
story changed to Brashear visiting the
grave of Candice receiving a visit from
Tony Stark Booker Bo does is establish
that the thoughts of Brashear regarding
his past the life he led and the way he
was treated
are fully behind him where he
acknowledges that he was previously
angry at his wife for deceiving him and
spending so many years lying about her
true role in his life
Brashear also realizes that during that
period of time the courage displayed in
Candace mirroring a black man was
astounding in and of itself what I mean
here is that during the 1960s in the
eyes of some Americans the worst offense
a white person could commit was
mirroring and procreating with an
african-american as such Brashear
realizes that the actions of Candace
quite literally put her life in danger
and that if someone was extreme enough
in the racism they would have sought her
out and intended to kill her for her
actions and so it's a discussion between
the two comes to an end and the story
begins to wind down stark officially
offers Brashear a place among the ranks
of the Avengers now where Adam doesn't
outright turn down the offer he does
acknowledge that there is at least some
part of him that needs to learn to adapt
to a new way of life outside the mindset
of his belief in constant racism to this
end after returning home he opens a
package left to him by Candice prior to
her death and after opening it finds a
uniform that she had made for him with a
message encouraging Adam to give the
world a chance and to take each person
as they are rather than allowing his
past to dictate his future
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and I really
hope you guys enjoy the blue Marvel
series post a comment below and let me
know what you guys thought and I will
catch you guys later peace